ouais
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission minutes forme le sud nicolas
votre coach aujourd'hui nous allons voir
le mouvement du box jump nous sommes
avec anaïs aujourd'hui bonjour anaïs ont
battu très très bien sûr d'inciter prêt
pour le prochain mouvement je vous
expliquer ce mouvement de boxe job vous
avez à l'occurrence aujourd'hui un
rocher nous pourrons utiliser un banc ou
un petit muret si vous êtes chez vous
allez démarrer légèrement fléchi sur vos
jambes pour effectuer un quart de squats
vous allez pousser sur vos jambes ont
utilisé dans les bras et atterrir en
quarts de squats également aux dalles
étendre les jambes suffisamment
contractant légèrement les cuisses de
possibilités descendre un pas après
l'autre si vous débutez si vous êtes à
l'aise
vous tendez et vous sautez up d'accord
tu démarres assure la première en
marchant et apprécié à l'aise tu
accélères un petit peu cette manière je
t'en prie à toi essayé d'écarter un tout
petit peu tes pieds au départ pensé
avoir un bon ancrage dans le sol ghazi
c'est parti sow est arrivé en haut tu
t'en les gens mais tu redescends
excellent elle va essayer d'accélérer le
mouvement ça va faire monter le rythme
cardiaque optenet temps bien les jambes
arrivant aux études et sans ce temps
voilà la même chose quand tu peux
utiliser tes bras n'hésitez pas utilisez
vos bras pour monter davantage encore
une
très bien tu t'arrêtes comment tu te
sens là hills où est ce que tu as honte
travailler le cardio est-ce que tu as
senti des muscles travaillent également
des mois lesquels
derrière la jambe très bien nous allons
est tirée après cet exercice les muscles
fessiers je vous conseille d'avoir une
jambe fléchit légèrement vous allait
placer la jambe opposée au dessus du
genou et on va les groupes et le tout
pour sentir vraiment au niveau des
fessiers
vous tirez au matin une vingtaine de
secondes et vous avez effectué cet
exercice des deux côtés bien entendu
prenez le temps de relâcher doucement
entre chaque répétition tu t'installes
tout on redresse se déplace-t-on pied
sur la jeune opposés et tu ramènes notre
ouverture attraper avec les deux mains
tu essaies de tirer vers toi
pour sentir au niveau des fessiers ça va
tu maintiens une vingtaine de secondes
je relâche tout doucement tu pas sur
l'autre côté
très bien
pensez à vous installer progressivement
et a relaxé progressivement pour chacun
de vos étirements
anaïs merci beaucoup à très bientôt
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis rendez
vous dans un prochain épisode de minutes
forme boxe comme fait 10 à 50
répétitions deux à quatre séries une à
deux fois par semaine pour éviter une
mauvaise réception toujours effectuer
une flexion de jambes au départ et à la
réception